hello I'm super Thomas I'm a software
developer here at Wolfram research in a
short while I will be giving a talk on
the microcontroller kit the
microcontroller kit automates the
generation and deployment of
microcontroller code from the Wolfram
language I have you with me a couple of
examples that I will demo during the
table it will be a very hands-on
presentation I hope you enjoy the
presentation and find the functionality
useful for your projects thank you
good morning and welcome to the stock on
the microcontroller kit so this is going
to be a very hands-on presentation so I
think a good introduction would be a
demo of a basic example so first let me
load the package and I'm also going to
set the port through which I will be
uploading code to the microcontroller
now what I have here is an Arduino Uno
with an LED connected to pin three and a
potentiometer connected to pin a zero I
would like for the microcontroller to
read the potentiometer value and adjust
the brightness of the LED based on that
it's very easy to get started with this
kit because there are only three user
level functions and two of them are
helper functions the main function is
this embed microcontroller code and it
takes three arguments the first argument
which is this one is the core function
that needs to run on the microcontroller
in this case it's a state space model
with one input and one output and the
input is directly fed through to the
output so if I look at the output
response if I give a sinusoidal input
it's going to give me back a sinusoidal
input if I give any arbitrary input it
will return that same input and this is
what I want I want the microcontroller
to read the potentiometer value and feed
that value directly through to the LED
the second argument has got to do with
the target hardware and this has three
sub arguments so the first one is the
name of the target itself which in this
case is the Arduino Uno the second one
is the list of inputs and the third is
the list of outputs so each input you
specify as the pin name and the
configuration in this case it's pin a
zero configured as an analog input and
then we do something similar for the
output we give the pin name and the
configuration in this case it's pin
three configured as an as an analog
output
and the last argument is the port
through which we will be uploading the
code to the microcontroller now it's a
state space model so it's an
input-output model so there is so if I
do an output response if you give any
input to it this particular one is going
to give back the same same output so now
if I evaluate this it's it's going to
upload the code onto this this target so
I get the second function in this
package which is which is a data object
and it tells me that it has generated
the source code and embedded the machine
code to the target so now because it's
uploaded here if I now adjust the
potentiometer the brightness of the LED
should change based on that I hope you
could see that from this data object we
can get other properties like we can ask
what was the source code that was that
was generated and there are a whole slew
of other properties that we can Kure
from the data object now here's a this
is a summary of the typical input and
output channels in a microcontroller we
just looked at the analog output and
analog input let's look at a few more
the bay one of the basic features in a
microcontroller is digital output here I
have an LED connected to pin 4 if the
pin value is high the LED is going to
turn on and if the pin value is low the
LED is going to turn off so to do that I
have a non linear state-space model
again with one output and it's a
constant high gain output it has no
inputs and the output is connected to
pin 4 so now if I evaluate that it
should turn on
led which was connected to pin 4 if I
make it a low value it should turn it
off now we can extend this to get the
LED blinking for that I create a non
linear state-space model with one state
with the status also the output and if
the state is high I turn it low and
otherwise if it's low I turn it on back
high and the sampling period becomes the
delays delay between the transitions so
now that LED should be blinking every
half a second now let's look at
something that's a bit more involved
which is a spi communication in SPI
communication there is a master device
and a bunch of slave devices the master
is responsible for the clock signal and
and it synchronizes all the devices on
the my so line which stands for master
input and slave output the slaves are
sending data to the master and on the
mosy line which stands for master output
and slave a master is outputting data to
the slaves at any one time the master is
talking to just one slave and the master
decides which slave is talking to by
making that slave select line of that
particular slave low so let's look an
example of this I have this Arduino that
I'm going to configure as a master spi
device and I'm going to get data from
this Mac 6 6 & 5 sensor which is a which
is a temperature sensor so all the lines
you see these are the serial clock this
is the master input slave output and
this is the chip select line the slave
select line which I have connected to
pin 7 now whenever we connect a device
to an Arduino like that we have to tell
what device it is and for that ambit
microcontroller code has this option SPI
this option SPI so under this option we
can enumerate all the SPI devices that
we have connected and so here I have
only one and the slave is uniquely
identified by its slave select pin so
this will generate code to read 2 bytes
from that sensor why 2 bytes because
that that's from the datasheet so now we
have got the data
next thing we have to do is pair it up
with with an input channel in general we
could have several slaves and several
input channels but this is the same
procedure for everything we will list
the the master input slave output pin
which for the Arduino Uno is the pin 12
and configure it is configure it as an
SPI pin so data is coming in through
that and then we have to say from which
slave the data is coming in and then we
have to say how to convert that data
again this recipe for converting those
two bytes into a temperature value that
that recipe comes from from the
datasheet and the output I'm going to
send over serial the reason I'm doing
that is because now I'm after this I'm
going to use the serial that the device
framework to read the temperature back
into Mathematica so let's embed that
code so now the code is running on the
Arduino it's getting the data and it's
sending it back over the over the serial
line so I'm going to use the device
framework I'm going to open a connection
to the data the data is coming in as
integer codes so I create a parsing
function that will convert it into
Wolfram language expressions and then I
set up a scheduled task which is reading
the data parsing it and appending it to
that list and now if I evaluate that it
should it's reading the temperature I'm
going to stick the end of this
thermocouple into some ice and it should
decrease
so we're able to to read this
temperature we are going able to embed
code and then use a device framework to
get the temperature back into
Mathematica now I'm going to remove that
task and close the device so let's look
at the third function in this package
the user level function that is
microcontroller targets this function
will give you the list of targets that
are supported so I can Curie for what
are the vendors whose boards we support
I can pick any one vendor and say what
boards from that vendor we support or I
can ask for what microcontroller
families are supported by this kit I can
pick one microcontroller family and say
what are all the boards that that are
based on that family that we support
so next okay next let's look at the
speed control example let me bring it up
on the camera
okay so over here I have the Arduino at
the bottom I have a motor shield in
in-between and a prototyping shield on
top the the reason I have that motor
shield is to boost the power of the
signal that is coming from the Arduino
during operation the motor will be
drawing much higher power than the rated
value of the of the Arduino pins I can
show it from here so I'm using this
potentiometer here to to set the
reference speed the speed I want the
motor to be turning it and that signal I
feel into this analog input a five the
actual speed of the motor is measured by
this encoder here at the back and I feed
it back into this digital pin - it's a
digital signal it's a sequence of pulses
by counting the number of pulses we know
how fast the the motor is going then
more the number of pulses the faster and
the fewer the slower the motor is going
and then the Arduino is going to compare
these two values and compute an
appropriate signal to send it's going to
send it on pin 11 it's going to send it
on pin 11 because the motor shield
passed at pin 11 to channel B - which
I've computer connected the two leads of
the motor to go ahead with the control
design I'll need two models I don't have
time in that this talk - to go over how
I derived that but I will point you to
the documentation later so the first
model is the model of the motor it
respirate models the speed of the motor
in response to an applied voltage and
the second one is an inverse as shield
model so it is mapping the the voltage
at the output of the shield which is the
voltage that is going to be applied to
the motor to the input signal at the
shield which is the PWM signal that's
coming from the Arduino we'll see in a
minute why why we need that
so I'm going to use the the motors model
and compute a controller using PID tune
and then discretize it with a sampling
period of of 0.5 seconds now that that
block I feed it into that inverse shield
the reason I'm doing that is because
this controller is computing the voltage
that needs to be applied to the motor
but in the physical setup the actual
voltage is being given by the motor
shield so what this block does is it
looks at the voltage that needs to be
applied to the motor and then based on
that voltage it computes the value of
the PWM signal that needs to be applied
by the Arduino to the motor shield so
that motor can even so that signal can
eventually reach the motor the input of
the PID controller is a comparator to
compare the two signals so the first
signal is the signal coming in from the
potentiometer the the potentiometer
reads a value between zero and five
volts and this motor is rated for 600
rpm so I would like but I would like to
max the speed off at 500 rpm so what
this block does is that it looks at the
applied the set voltage and converts it
that into an RPM value from 0 to 500 and
I'm doing something similar for the
encoder all these numbers come from the
datasheet of the encoder 12 is the
number of car number of pulses per
revolution of the of the of the motor
shaft and it is coupled with by a
gearbox to the actual output shaft and
so this product will give counting the
number of pulses per revolution of the
output shaft and the inverse of that
multiplied by the input of this is going
to give me the number of revolutions and
I'm counting those revolutions every
sampling period so this divided by the
sampling period is revolutions per
second multiplied by 60 revolutions per
minute so at this point both the units
are RPM the long and short of this
computation is that
takes pulse counts raw pulse counts and
converts it into an RPM value okay after
I get all these components I can
assemble the assemble the controller and
then I'm so I have the first I have the
first argument to ambit 2 n-bit
microcontroller code now I'm going to
specify the target is of course Arduino
Uno which is at the bottom I'm going to
specify the inputs and outputs the first
input is the analog signal the reference
signal coming from the potentiometer is
connected to pin a5 the second one is
the digital input that is coming through
pin 2 now there are several ways you can
come you can count the pulses you can
count either the rising edges of the
pulses or you can count the falling
edges of a pulse or you can also count
the number of toggles the pulses making
if I if I said change this to the number
of toggles I'll have to double this make
it 24 but I just chose to go with the
rising edge so I'm just counting the
rising edge so that will give me the
number of the number of pulses now for
the output the output is the PWM signal
it's scaled from 0 to 100 that's on pin
11 and so all these 2 inputs and this
output that's all I need for the speed
controller but I'm going to add two
additional outputs and the reason these
are both serial outputs the reason I add
these outputs is for me to again use the
device framework and get it back into
Mathematica so I can visualize the set
and actual speeds so let me embed that
I should change this reevaluate that
so I'm going to do something similar
that I did with did with the temperature
reading I'm going to open a connection
to that device I'm going to create a
parsing function that's going to change
the raw bytes that are coming in into
Wolfram language expressions and I'm
going to set up a scheduled task that's
reading the data parsing it and
appending it to a list and then I can
which one
um yeah I think I think it mr. bite let
me try this again okay there was it
probably dropped a bite when it was
getting the data in okay so now
everything is at rest I'm going to give
it a step input and I'm just turning the
put potential I'm ramping it up so you
see the this is the controller
responding to the said speed it takes
some time to do to reach the speed that
was said but if I change it gradually
then it will do a better input tracking
so this is a metric of how good the
controller is doing how well it tracks
the input under the metric is we can
give it a disturbance and see how well
that responds to our disturbance again
if I give a gradual disturbance and
gradually take it off it's good but if I
give a sudden disturbance it takes a
while for the controller to realize and
if I abruptly take it again it takes a
while for it to realize that there is no
more load before bringing it back okay
so what what are the benefits of using
the microcontroller so in one word it
automates a lot of things so from proof
imbed microcontroller code does a lot of
things behind the scenes the first thing
it does is it generates the source code
and then it invokes a compiler to
compile that into a binary format and
then it invokes a programmer to to take
that binary code and passes it through
an external program onto the
microcontroller so so most of this is
also automated in other platforms like
the arduino ide or the Atmel studio but
the added advantage here is that we are
also automatically generating the source
code so why is that important if you
look at a tip a typical development
cycle we are developed we are getting a
controller or a filter from a model and
then we are generating code and
and deploying it and going into testing
and verification so anytime that there
is a change in the requirements or there
are enhancements or Corrections in the
model or if there are improvements in
the in the controller of filter design
will have to regenerate the code also if
if you make some changes in the physical
hardware to its it can be a tedious
process to actually regenerate that code
so this adds a level of automation which
streamlines the entire process and
another advantage is it generates hard
real-time code so at each sampling
instant the microcontroller is doing a
bunch of tasks and there is no control
on how much time it will take to
complete the task at each time and after
that it is essentially idle except for
any interrupts it will have to service
but this code it it does not depend it
does not see it is not a delay after
that it does not see after that how long
it takes at each sampling period after
that time it exactly starts doing the
whole sequence again so we enforce hard
real-time constraints in this so in
closing the microcontroller kit enables
a streamlined and uniform workflow to
rapidly iterate and deploy code to
microcontrollers there are three main
symbols embed micro controller code
micro controller code data and micro
controller targets micro controller code
is the main one and we have ref pages
and examples for for all of all the all
the three there are also there's also
several tutorial pages and tutorials and
ref page is going to have go into much
more detail and have way more examples
than I've been able to present here you
also develop several projects I just
showed you one but but there are others
too we be like an analog filter
realization or a line following control
in in these we we we list what are the
parts you need how to assemble them how
to get the model how to design things we
go the whole process step by step so
you will be able to to replicate what we
have done yeah so that concludes my talk
thank you very much
[Applause]